today's topic
quevo and sweet tea um
so let's play the video
[Music]
foreign
so what are your thoughts when are
situations like that
the message violence something that is
out there we have to be very careful
about it
we have to hold people accountable for
what they're doing
when they're engaging in those toxic
behaviors
we have to we have to
know when it happens but one thing i
know and i've been able to find out
is aside from people that are blatantly
we know there's some people
that are blatantly uh violent and just
go for it but there's other people that
instigate the fight
instigators and we don't talk often
about it
whether it's male or female the people
that instigate the fight
the people that throw the punch the
people that are in your face what you
gonna do about this
what you gonna do what you gonna do huh
huh what you gonna do
or punch and fix you and touch you and
get in your physical bubble
man or woman they want a reaction out of
you
and then things pop off and go out of
proportion
right that could lead to the strongest
blow
or the deadliest blow into some instance
and that's very unfortunate
that it gets there instigators no it's
not victim blaming i'm not saying that
the victim blame it but you have to take
a look
at your action in situation
i'm looking at this video and people are
like going off on coivo
going on for the person that's the man
that's in the video
not not looking at the part first person
that threw the punch now even that video
is not the full thing that happened we
don't know what happened before we don't
know what happened after i know that he
was pulling on his bag
hence pulling on her and she fell down
and hurt herself
she hurt she got hurt in the process and
that's bad the whole situation is bad
but without victim blaming and saying
what do you what
could you have done better to you know
to avoid a situation that's not what
we're trying to do
but there are enough situations i've
witnessed myself
working in the bar industry and seeing
couples together
seeing people together in in in
out there in the streets there is the
instigating fact
and the the instigating factor there's
an instruct and interesting
statistics that says that women are as
likely to be as
violent as men and women that are in
violent relationship
are often violent themselves
often i'm not saying all i'm not saying
people that are suffering
from someone that is just violent and
having like a regiment of terror
is doing that but we have to counter we
have to talk about that fact
we have to talk about that the
instigating because that
gets transported into another
relationship into another relationship
their kids from those relationship those
kids learn
those patterns and repeat those patterns
and that's what we have to attack we
have to hold
everybody accountable not only the
person that hits and that can't handle
his emotion
but also the person that instigate and
push
and nag man or woman i've seen men and
women do
both again this is not blaming
at all at all
this is some things that happen and i've
seen it from both
and we have we have to
atta we have to go through that we have
to
we we have to uh address that the
instigating part what
makes things you know when you're making
the thing out of the thing that is not a
thing
that without them blaming
there are victims out there yup but
they're also instigators
and you got 20 more disclaimers you want
to put on
that's what i do the slimmer i can tell
this is how your whole half of spielberg
i'm not
blaming one sentence i'm not blaming
two sentences i'm not blaming but i'm
not victim blaming
what you got to say just before he says
this he's not
than blaming apparently listen
and what kind of altercation do you see
a man leaving with his bags
the girl swings first and then somehow
in the media they're still portraying
him as the aggressor
i just don't understand it flip the
genders let's say it's a woman and then
he tries to swing at her
she gets away from the swing and she
comes out as a perpetrator
in what world would that ever happen
people would have been good for you not
a single time
in fact if he would have started wailing
on him after he fell
everyone would have been like good he
would still be the perpetrator you know
and
it's just interesting to me like the
whole media narrative around this no of
course we wouldn't say we don't know
what happened before we did not have
after
clearly she chased him down am i wrong
no you're not wrong
clearly she blocked his path am i wrong
you're not wrong clearly she swung at
him
with a hook you're not wrong she tried
to grab his bags it's not an improper
technique though
but it was awkward
it helped even if it's not a good hook
all right so when i see this stuff it
just
once again goes back to the same fact
that the idea that men are always seen
as the ones who can do the violence and
women is never the case
even though from my personal experience
and things that i've seen women initiate
just as much if not more because they
feel more comfortable doing so
so for me looking at this i was just
like of course
it's the same type of media narrative
that you're always going to hear ladies
can do no wrong
that's what it comes down to so for me i
see this and i'm just like
okay and my point isn't that he's in the
wrong or she's in the wrong my point is
this
we don't know so it's crazy for me to
see people dealing with such a narrative
like
100 percent this and you want some
victim blaming i don't care
just say it say it assume oh yeah i've
been preaching
okay cool whatever you say she found she
first off
okay he didn't throw her to the ground i
have it on camera
she didn't throw her to the ground he
was grabbing his stuff and then she was
leaning
she goes down so slow she was holding on
to that so so
you know let's let's let's not run with
these fake stores
um but listen that's my thoughts on that
this
is more of the same when it comes to
these kinds of topics
men are always the one who are in the
wrong so guys
do whatever you can protect yourself at
all costs just like he did
you know what i'm saying when he didn't
throw a punch at her don't do it
now because if you would have thrown it
i promise you even though she just threw
one before i promise you he would be
getting
wrecked right now so at least he was
smart enough to do that and ladies
don't be touching our video games okay a
lot of y'all do that that's just weird
because you know how much we like it
and you know the moment we leave we go
play video games and not think about you
for hours
so y'all try to destroy our but
that's the thing okay do they not
destroy the playstation first
i don't know i know i don't know my girl
knows better
she will never that we we don't touch we
don't touch
each other no we don't touch each
other's stuff but we don't that's not
the dynamic at all but that's none of
your business
that's not the dynamic at all but
anyways
i've seen that they they try to do
everything to sustain
a reaction yep so i'm gonna key your car
yep i'm gonna go after your playstation
and then when you react what happens i'm
gonna rip your
your clothes and then when you wreck
what happens well happy happy exactly
rip your clothes i'm gonna try to burn
your thing you know waiting to exhale
kind of
yeah listen um i don't know what their
relationship is i don't know what's
going on so i'm not gonna put a
referendum on them me just looking at
this in a vacuum that's
that's what i was thinking when i
watched it so you wanted our thoughts
there you have it anything else no no
all right well let us know what you guys
think in the comments below who was
wrong
who was right did anybody destroy your
playstation we want to hear what
happened
where did they touch you where did they
touch the playstation let us know where
did they touch fingers
can you show me on this playstation
where you got text
[Music]
foreign